we had the mid-season finale Spencer
gets shot yeah
is Spencer dead would they really do
that to us I can't really comment as to
whether I'm there in flashbacks or there
in the flesh but it was uh this is the
end of this show so yes it's absolutely
possible that I could be dead how did
you react when you heard the show was
ending why is this the right time um I
think it's the right time because people
have been watching us for seven years I
think it was great to do the five-year
time jump and to get so much time to
wrap up these stories and to kind of
move on with the girls lives but you
know I think all good things must come
to an end and I I'm really really
excited to share the closing of this
story was every with everybody I think
it's gonna be really fun what can you
tease us about the final episode every
question that you have will be answered
and that's the most exciting thing there
will come a time when you won't even
have questions anymore because they will
all be answered which is so exciting we
found out that you are Mary Drake's
secret daughter what can you tell us
about that and what will that change
Spencer at all uh well if she survives
it's fascinating to find out the origin
story of Spencer and especially for me
it's been so wonderful as somebody who's
kind of always seen Spencer's the black
sheep of her family and somebody who's
always struggling so hard to fit in and
then she has these impulses that she
doesn't understand these mental issues
that she struggles with issues of
addiction issues with impulsivity issues
of you know this is sort of its like
fractured self and when you get to hear
more about Mary Drake and more about
where Spencer comes from it makes so
much sense